if you look at the middle three speeches
you've got these three guys yeah this
came up last class you know these are
kind of the intellectual heavyweights of
Athens I forget exactly who we asked the
question why are these you know sort of
the intelligentsia and they're part of
not just the professional class they're
also part of the you might call them
entertainment industry but this has had
a bigger role in in ancient Greece
poetry dramatic production than it does
for us where I think in a lot of cases
unless we get angry about you know what
we saw on a movie or a TV show we write
a letter to the editor we think of it as
something that we we consume and just
sort of enjoy for the Greeks
each one of these guys is tied in with
something particularly important and
what's more each one of them by virtue
of the kind of work that they're doing
has a claim to being wise to being
somebody who can tell you how you ought
to live your life about important issues
now you know you might say I only go to
my doctor when I feel sick you know what
does the doctor have to tell me about
things well as you get older if they
start telling you things like look you
know if you want to live longer you're
gonna have to change your diet start
exercising more quit smoking but also
doctors typically to quit drinking drink
less
those are usually the big ones you know
quit eating fatty foods quit eating
salty stuff quit eating sweet foods
notice fanny salty sweet those are the
things we like to have to eat the most
right so that's early doctors are always
saying no more fun for you but why are
they actually doing that because health
is a good and health as part of the good
life this is a matter of fact health is
part of the long life so if you want to
be able to enjoy it you know your
doctors probably gave probably giving
you fairly good advice and medicine is
advanced you know what bit past the time
of thinking in terms of bodily humors
and remedies that they could come up
with but they actually have quite a few
good ideas back in that time and Eric's
Emma cast is sort of a typical
representative of the medical profession
at the time the medical art is one of
the oldest arts or sciences around it
goes you know back to to the beginnings
you know philosophy spun off a lot of
other disciplines many of the other
things that you're studying like
psychology or sociology the Natural
Sciences all those were you know
originally the part of philosophy
Natural Sciences were from natural
philosophy and they got spun off
Madison was around before that
mathematics was also around another m12
music so those are all well-established
arts what about these two guys
Aristophanes and Agatha one is a comic
playwright and one is a tragic
playwright means they rent comedies and
tragedies and you guys have all seen
like those you know those masks you have
one smiling and one crying that's
supposed to represent comedy of tragedy
right as comedies about what laughing
and fun stuff and you know situations
people get into that that are funny or
things like that and tragedy is about
what being sad yeah sooner or later I
mean a lot of other things happen on a
way but you know when Odysseus fun or
not Odysseus when Oedipus fight enough
that indeed it was his father that he
killed and his mother who he married and
by whom he he sired a whole brood of
children he's he's more than sad but the
actually gouges his eyes as mom hangs
herself and the rest of the kids are all
screwed up but you know sad is sort of a
good description for that tragedies are
about noble characters who find
themselves really through no fault of
their own circumstances coming together
with you know what seem to be random
events but are often fate and then some
you know some problem that they have got
something they're unable to make sense
of things collapse Shakespeare wrote
comedies
we do nowadays laughing called tragedies
dramas or thrillers comedies we still
call comedies and you know we've got a
lot of different kinds of companies
you've got Netflix you guys all use
Netflix or Hulu or something like that
you click on comedy you get a whole
drop-down menu you know sketch a company
screwball comedy romantic comedy there's
like 15 of them right even by
nationality British comedy comedy is
something distinct kind of comedy that
he was writing we talked about this a
little bit last time it was old comedy
it was very wrong it tended to take
people from the actual city of Athens
sometimes other places to and put them
into these these crazy situations make
fun of people there was actually like a
part of the play like I told you about
where the actors have to take off their
masks come down into the audience and
just start yelling at people you are a
terrible person
so it's sort of like a roast at a
certain point you guys ever watch those
Comedy Central roasts pretty if you
watch the uncensored ones pretty you
know vicious stuff but we give a kick
out of that and the ancient Greeks got a
kick out of that too
you know part of comedy is watching
people trip over things and fall down
him and provided it's not you or
somebody to care about it it can be
funny so Aristophanes is part of that
genre the Agathon is the new new rising
star of tragedy on the scene and now
what's really interesting is these guys
don't actually provide you with the
comedy or a tragedy within the symposium
it would be too long right you don't
have time for character development or
you know whole plot things like that so
what do they do
Erick's abacus gives a physical
explanation
you'd expect a doctor to do that right
let's go you know go to a party and say
yeah but having these neck pains and you
think you could tell me something about
it with doctors as well it's because of
this and this you know but wound in the
neck is doing this thing to the nerve
they're giving you a physical
explanation right they're not
Aristophanes Eric Symmachus does this
for all sorts of things all across the
board well we'll look at that in a
moment
Aristophanes tell us what we'd call a
fable you know sometimes we we talk
about these sort of like folk stories
right
grim get out are together all sorts of
folk stories that are kind of along
these lines and then are they supposed
to teach you something yeah but they're
also supposed to entertain and you might
not have been super entertained by
Aristophanes story reading it through
but it is pretty funny and the way that
he describes things is you know take any
comic and if you think through some of
the implications that you know it gets
more and more laughable but it's also
supposed to teach you something about
human nature about the way we are then
we're actually not what we think we are
so it's going beyond the appearances to
the realities and Athan doesn't give you
a tragedy
there's no characters in it it's all
just about love what he does instead is
he gives you a really well-constructed
rhetorical speech now is anybody here
going into communications you also doing
this I mean law political science and
one going into political science okay so
you want to pay attention to what's
called rhetoric that rhetoric is the art
of finding the means the way Aristotle
defined it rhetoric is the art to the to
finding the means of persuasion finding
the ways to be able to get people to do
things and this doesn't just go for
communications people or psychology or
political science business people need
to pay
to this because persuasion is part of
motivation Aristotle actually says all
education involves persuasion to some
extent you have to persuade the audience
about what it is that you're trying to
you know inform them about get them to
believe it and you have to actually get
them to do their if you get them to
actually do the work that you want them
to do to change their their thinking
about things
Agathon puts together this really nice
speech it's an argument he says I'm
going here's what we ought to do and we
give speeches about this sort of thing
here is what I'm gonna do and here's the
first part of my argument here's the
second part of my argument and now I'm
going to open up the floodgates and show
off how ho you know flashy I can be at
the very end after I've done the work
after I've done the here's an argument
hey here's argument B here's the points
in favor of this you probably didn't
catch that reading it through but that's
the structure of it who did you learn to
do this from from one of the famous
Sophists Gorgas who hung out in Athens
sometimes and actually did take money
for teaching he apparently made so much
money that he was able to have a statue
of himself made in his hometown I would
have gold life-sized that's a lot of
gold so he really made a lot of money
teaching this sort of thing does he
think it's not actually know what he's
talking about when he's giving this
great speech
what happens soon after that Socrates
starts asking some questions right so
we'll hold off on it is let's turn out
with this guy Eric Simitis often times
Erickson MCUs is portrayed as if he's a
real bore or prove you know this guy
who's half the party and he you know
everybody else has got these great
speeches about human beings and what the
way they used to be or how great love is
and this guy wants to talk about the
seasons and harmony and things like that
and give this well if you understand the
elements seems kind of boring like the
person who shows up at the party on a
Friday night and wants to talk shop
about what they were studying in class
that day and everyone else is like you
know we had enough of that right but it
but actually is not he's is giving you
some really interesting ideas to play
with about the nature of luck and I'm
always forgetting how to write his name
so he's picking up from this guide puff
Sonya so we looked at last class right
what did post audience have to say about
love what do you remember from that
yeah so that's a key thing right there
good luck yeah there's bad luck well
anything else here that struck you yeah
good luck was heavenly and that it was
earthly very good so I'm sorry I said
that there's a fundamental difference
between us
remember we talked about when people say
platonic log what they often have in
mind is what else audience is talking
about
well Sonic's also made it about gender
too right
you know the good log is going to be
between men and men because the Greeks
have these these kind of you know crazy
notions about women Socrates by the way
is going to subvert this because who's
the smartest person in the room by the
end of the story yodeler right whereas
you know the bad love could be between
anybody whatsoever Erik's amicus is
going to keep some of this it's going to
keep the good notion between good law
and bad laws is it going to be about
what's heavenly and what's earthly is
that going to be a distinction that he's
gonna make though no because because the
earthly stuff can have good love and the
heavenly stuff as it turns out can have
bad luck right
that's what the seasons don't work the
way they're supposed to you and you get
terrible storms
that's bad love up in the heavens is it
is good luck just about the soul or is
it also about the body for Erickson that
this is just bad luck and they love
being the soul
yeah they can have equal to objects so
what's a fine it's good and they had
love good or good and bad it also brings
up this term desires now if you're a bit
puzzled about that when I asked you that
question there's good reason he doesn't
actually tell her he invokes this idea
but doesn't explain this idea something
you want to pay attention to when you're
reading text somebody might say yeah
here's here's this great idea but unless
they actually unpack it for you now to
explain it maybe it's not such a great
idea maybe it's just something that
they're saying but it's not actually
that informative but it does seem to
imply is that good love is some sort of
permanent the ad love is some sort of
sport right so you know think back to
how sanyasis good loving bad well let's
say that here's a classic situation
right what happens when when two guys
are interested in the same girl or two
girls are interested in the same guy the
two that are after the same object get
along most of the time what would happen
is instead yeah argument discord they
had this is they have competing desires
competing motives they can't both have
the thing that they want you know we
don't even have to take you know
romantic relationships if all of us want
the same candy bar you know and we're
not content to say there's like what 25
people in here these are just gonna get
a little tiny bit of candy I want the
candy bar for me and maybe I'll share it
with a few other people and each one of
you is thinking the same thing we're not
lesson we're not going to be anything a
long marriage we're gonna be jarring
with each other we're going to be
competing now that's you know that's
desire that's love right love does make
us do crazy things
harmony is when everything comes
together and fits together and nobody is
compelled everybody is able to get what
they need out of it you know Eric
something kiss is gonna say this doesn't
just hold for like romantic Affairs or
dividing up candy bars this holds for
the body itself not just our bodies with
the bodies of every living thing plants
animals talk about that but we have
bacteria you know other kingdoms and
does it just stop there no it also has
to do with our soul and it has to do
with things like music and it has to do
with the entire cosmos itself the entire
world considered as one big system can
be in harmony or it can be all bollocks
tough and fighting with itself and you
know sort of churning in and making all
sorts of monsters and things like that
sort of things that happen in Green's
myth even the gods can be in harmony
with each other or fighting with each
other and you know if you know your
Greek mythology did the Greek gods
always get along no no I mean they they
are terrible Zeus is always screwing
around on his wife and the queen of the
gods mother of his has three kids
Hades just you know likes Persephone one
day so he steals her that her mother's
so ticked off she says I'll let
everything die until I get her back
everything's gonna die me these are you
know I'm not gonna say necessarily mean
or cruel gods but they're definitely not
always thinking of the whole system no
taking everybody into it yeah they're
kind of selfish aren't they
hermes is actually a thief he was like
stealing stuff he actually steals from
his brother Paul for fun the guidance
can sometimes have harmonious
relationships though to him and human
beings can be in harmony with the gods
in harmony with the divine or out of our
maitland so this entire thing is covered
what determines whether you're in
harmony so Erika Simic is gonna talk in
terms
well I say that word what what occurs to
you what class comes to mind for my
school chemistry right because we think
in terms of I don't even know how many
elements there are you guys remember I'm
sure it's different from when I was in
high school than College clover hunters
right so now we have to review the chart
I suppose again how many are there
remember at least like 110
anyway there's that's a lot elements and
what makes them elements why do we call
them that why do they give you this big
chart
Oh
the rare earths and once we it's really
interesting the radioactive ones
yeah
that's why we have a chart yeah
what are we organized don't just say the
elements that's kind of circular okay
well make some elements yeah structure
okay yeah that that's true we you know
we have atomic structure and we know
that even the atomic structure isn't the
whole shebang that each one of the
particles is made up of other verticals
we've got four arcs by the time if you
guys have grandkids those grandkids will
be telling you telling you about some
other thing that they learned that's an
even deeper level most likely but the
elements are obviously they're not
blocks right but they're the basic
components of things degrees if they had
a physical way of looking at things they
have this four element what we call
physics or comedy air earth vital water
this is kind of widespread throughout
you know the ancient world and continued
through the medieval period even in the
early modern period there are a lot of
people still thinking in terms of these
things do you know do we do we can now
consider those elements no yeah but they
did and you can also go one level deeper
what made earth what it is what gave it
its qualities earth is cold and hard
solid and dry
right yeah sometimes you get these mixed
up
Eric Simic this is gonna talk in terms
just a few these qualities like the hot
Nicole the wet and the dry and notice he
talks about some that are taste
perceptions the sweet and the bitter no
damn log is when these things actually
jar with each other when they don't get
along when the elements are out of
accord with each other
good love is when they can be brought
into harmony with each other let's say
we get away from elements like earth air
fire water that sort of thing and we
think about parts of our body how many
of you are feeling particularly good
today maybe yeah yeah I don't even feel
a little sick made me feel sick Wow must
be something going around that's that's
right that means I'm probably gonna get
sick too how many of you are starting in
between ok so when you're sick what's
happening usually it's like something
comes in from the outside and messes you
up
alright like any other gym if you have
allergies right now something in the air
is interacting with your sinuses or you
know screwing up your histamine system
we have all these interesting
explanations for these things some of
you might be sick because we have a
virus or there's some bacteria within
you that's that's messing you up it's
attacking your cells and your body is
actually engaging in reactions that you
don't like the feeling of like fever
when you get a fever that's not the
bacteria of making that fever that's
your body saying let's turn up the heat
in here so we can cook these bacteria
and hopefully not cook the rest of the
body but that would be sort of being out
of out of sorts with yourself right and
can't your body sometimes turn against
itself what are what are cases like that
these diseases that come about where the
body itself is kind of breaking itself
down what comes to mind
cancer is a perfect example cells go
crazy cells are supposed to reproduce
right because if they don't we're
screwed we die you don't have the same
cells that you started with you shifted
through a couple different sequences of
them cancer they just like say it's all
I'm doing it's reproducing and I'm going
to take all the resources from over
there and if I have to spill over to
this space that's that's just fine
that's what makes cancer cancer think
about diabetes huge problems in this
country
what's going on with diabetes I need to
shoot yourself up
yeah you're not your body is no longer
producing something that it ought to be
doing some of the elements are out of
discord some of the organs we would
probably say all right they're not doing
what they should be doing they're doing
something but God knows what it is and
they're laying down on the job screws up
things for everything else and then
those things get out of my acting let's
cause other problems and these are just
kill pit and used to be a few had
diabetes sliced five generations ago
your dad that's it your cancer same
thing nowadays we can actually treat a
lot of these things and what is
treatment for areas that like this it's
reintroducing good love into the body he
talks about the doctor he has being able
to there's a sort of a listing of things
he can understand and distinguish the
different lofts and desires and work in
the body he can help encourage the good
elements and discourage the bad elements
determine which desires will have to be
satisfied and how much here use a sort
of prosaic example and if you ever had
model do then I had mono might my
freshman year of high school and towards
the very end of the freshman year and I
went you know last track through the
year agree on it wasn't feeling well and
I collapsed and so they you know it took
me to the doctor and sure enough you got
mono and when you got mono that first
you feel really bad right
it's pretty pretty horrible and students
sometimes you're at Marist get it
but then there's a dangerous period
you still have your body is still full
of mana but you feel good and your
doctor will tell you you need to take it
easy don't do any exercise don't exert
yourself no stress
you've got a heal and then you know of
course you feel good right so what do
you want to do after you have to you
have been sick for a while what's the
natural thing I'm going to go out and
enjoy myself for me it was like I could
start working out again and my doctor
told me straight up you are you cannot
work out
did I ask them I didn't listen to them
they're freaking out again and then the
next time I went to see the doctor and
they took a blood culture he said now
you have to lay in bed all summer all
summer long can you imagine that because
I didn't listen to them because he
understood according to Derek so mcus he
understood what the actual good desires
and bad desires of my body were in this
case a bad desire was hey go back to
your normal routine the good desire
which I didn't have was laying back
whenever you know when you're 15 years
old do you want to lay in bed all day I
think so nope if you do then you have to
close the doctor what else route out the
bad loves and then in place good loves
within us that's what the medical earth
should be doing according to Aronson
like us what about other Earth's think
about music we tend to look at music is
again what consumer item you all have
your all you have smartphones right on
your smartphone you have a
I pod of one form or another I don't
know does Android just call it an mp3
player because they don't like the I
thing just apples that the devil order
yeah something like that so you have an
mp3 player
how many mp3s just off the top of your
head would you guess that you yeah they
just asked you
no now mp3 players mp3 mp3 files Pony
songs
2001
what about a good about you get there 1
700 that's that's kind of small
what's that oh you just don't don't have
a ton of music at this point I have just
with you know nineteen eighties heavy
metal stuff I have something like six
days worth of music playing that I could
play constantly I forget how many
thousands long sentence but it gives you
an idea about how much we just sort of
you know see music is something that we
can manipulate how many of you have
played an instrument and I don't mean
here at Marist but you know like a
middle school or high school or
elementary school quite a few yeah so
you remember what it's like to have to
learn an instrument and hopefully you
wasn't all a chore you actually had some
joy in it at one point after you
mastered it and could play with other
people how much of the time are you guys
listening to music to think other than
any given day do you listen to it when
you drive in your car or do you listen
to the news or just turn it all off and
enjoy sweet silence Carlos what about
when your study you listen to music when
you're studying or writing
what else working out like music when
you're working on
going to sleep is there some code
obviously someplace you can't get away
from this driving driving yeah
maybe listen to music several hours a
day if you tally it up now those people
that are worried about music having
effects on us do you think they're just
full of it or does music actually have
some sort of effects on us not
necessarily the lyrics that's what they
always focusing on yeah but think about
the music itself yeah
yeah that's that's a great example you
find yourself moving to the to the
rhythm whether you like it or not yeah
you're exactly right
and you know think about events why do
we play music at events because it helps
to produce the same sort of feeling
across the crowd and they kind of play
off of each other you know if you go to
a if you go to a concert or a club or
something like that and there's music
playing but nobody's dancing then you
feel a little self-conscious dancing
everybody else is doing it then you get
into the the feeling of it yeah it's
kind of a group experience so Eric
Symmachus talks about music in terms of
its elements and all that but we want to
think about this in terms of music's
effect on the soul as well in music
itself saying inculcate good and bad
desires or awaken them or arouse them
what would the musician do
you know with the practitioner of the
art of music
these are anybody who can actually bring
about certain effects imagine you look
at great producers that's part of what
they do that's part of what they're
attempting to this track needs to be in
here because it's gonna have this kind
of psychological effect it's very
difficult to articulate we're not good
at that sort of thing sort of like wine
tasting it's very difficult to say
exactly what a wine tastes like but we
know that there is some sort of effect
for Erikson because it comes from these
elements and whether we have harmony or
disharmony
finally he gets to you know things like
like sacrifice and divination and there
we could be motivated by good or bad
love this gets kind of interesting I'm
gonna skip over the seasons thing
because we're going to talk about that
divination and sacrifice is a way for us
to be interacting with the divine now
for the ancient Greeks they have those
gods like Apollo and Zeus and Poseidon
and Athena and you know whether they
really believed in them or not is kind
of hazy and you know when you talk to
something like Socrates it gets really
even further easier because he's got
some strange notions
disguise himself what they did engage in
sacrifice they did engage in visitation
interestingly enough who else to the
Greeks sort of classify society
different parents very common thing in
ancient world for Parenthood to be
invested with a quasi divine status why
because you're bringing about new life
you're making a new being
and part of piety what we call filial
piety was this proper you know behavior
towards towards your parents sometimes
it could get kind of twisted Aristotle
for example brings up a guy who dragged
his father bodily you know out by the
hair just as far as the threshold and
said you know when somebody said really
you shouldn't be beating your father he
said well you know he he beat his father
before his father beat the father before
that so I'm his continuing tradition but
they only went this far as is the
doorway the threshold so I'm well within
proper limits that's kind of a
screwed-up notion I feel alike but it
shows that the Greeks did have this
notion Eric's impetus thinks that these
things can be understood in terms of
good desires and bad designers now it's
not the doctor who's gonna like set me
right with that
thing and implant the good desires and
take out the bad desires
it's unclear who does that but
presumably there would be somebody who
does that and this is what log really is
about for Eric Zemeckis it's it's a
process based on weather elements are
synchronized with each other or out of
accord with each other there are some
practitioners who can make it work it's
a very technological view on it is
something that we can manipulate
something that we can work but one other
thing I want to say about Eric Semak is
very quickly he gives you this
impression that the role of the doctrine
of all of the other people involved in
this is to try to you know promote this
but let us enjoy this event just like
with food right we're drinking really
it's better for us if we don't drink it
all and we eat healthy food but you know
can you eat some unhealthy food yeah and
and you know life would be less
enjoyable if we didn't get to do some of
this but not too much right Eric so my
guess is the guy saying don't drink too
much
have some does not make sense could you
apply this to other things
let's think about sexual relationships
now ones that are supposed to be
committed that would be a great example
of something that's really is you could
picture Erik Simic is saying something
like you know it's okay to cheat a
little bit not not go hog-wild with this
sort of thing but you know maybe within
certain limits that that's okay maybe
that's that's gonna be more enjoyable
more more healthy like you know example
this 500 mile rule
yes familiar with this movie I think
about this like if you're five you know
if you're in a committed relationship so
long as you're within 500 miles of your
boyfriend/girlfriend spouse you have to
stay faithful but if you're walk further
than five miles I thank you too and then
you'll be a little bit happier when you
when you come back now does that sort of
thing work what do you think what's your
impression of that what I wanted to say
something like that sounds pretty good
but he says hey that's probably playing
with fire or I really wouldn't want my
partner to do that
I'm just in the last year my wife has
been in Seattle or else just to go to
San Antonio sometimes I think I don't
want to 500-mile roll in place yeah good
reasons probably hey man that's very
cynical speech let's let's look now at
in on Aristophanes and Aristophanes is
like totally shifting gears after he
gets over his bout of hiccups that Eric
summit has prescribed him a remedy for
Aristophanes tells you this this crazy
story about these people
[Music]
nothing's of these people then that
light was giving a terrible Drive you
know you've read the thanks to you you
know what we're done right
there's the original human being smiling
because they're so happy
original condition
they roll around you know they're super
powerful one of them I forget to put it
what's up yeah I suppose I should put
hands and feet down there but you're
right there's something else though
that's really important to the story
heart man gasps you'd have to have
something a public one yeah what's up
yeah genitals you know reproductive
organs and you know we definitely do a
couple of these because some of them
were male male they had you know choose
that's a male apparatus here some had
two sets of female parts some they had
one of each right and those are the
androgynous ones that hermaphrodites of
ancient your and this is what we were
originally and because these beings were
so strong they started making trouble
for the guys and you know there's always
some sort of flying anything that
doesn't there and they they actually
tried to storm happen now you know
that's sort of like dropping the nuclear
bomb trying to try to take the God's
abode away that will if anything that
will set the gods alive and they're like
we got to do something about these
people because they are just causing so
much trouble but they're in a quandary
right what the gods want for human
beings sacrifices and this is a very
literal idea you know in the ancient
world you see this in culture after
culture the idea is you've got something
like meat and you take the best parts of
the meat and you burn them on the altar
and the the smoke goes up to heaven and
the gods consume the app and they
nowadays and then actually the gods
consume the spiritual essence of it and
then what happens to the meat after that
those are why people like doing
sacrifices everyone else eats the meat
you know or the the cereal offerings are
picked whatever else you got it was one
of the occasions in the ancient world
where you actually did get to eat meat
that was fairly regular so people people
really got a good kick out of this and
the gods got a big kick out of it -
apparently not exactly sure how that
worked but Aristophanes kind of losses
over there so they don't want to just
kill these people off you know the great
flood or letting Zeus zap them all with
lightning or fire because then they
won't have sacrifices so they're in a
real quandary well Zeus says here the
solution just cut them right down the
middle cut him in half
and then we'll do a little bit of you
know reworking and stitching in
something that's what he gets the gods
are good at that sort of thing to come
one and they turn the head around so you
know imagine this was actually the cut
part he doesn't say that they must have
turned the legs and arms around in the
story - right - face the right way they
turn the head around so I could look at
this this gaping hole
this is wound you know but they actually
pull the skin tight and tie it up at the
Belle époque so that's you know if you
have an Audi as they say yours is
showing more if it's pushed in then you
know your little knot of your skin is
hidden and they left a few you know
wrinkles in the belly and they smooth
out the chest
and you know added a few features here
and there now what happened to the
sexual organs well those had to be moved
around in the front as well because the
problem was these two hands of the
original thing they started to feel
desire and this is what the story is
really about desire for what
what are these beings desire
somebody to take something away from you
that you really took for granted yeah I
mean you know if somebody burns your
house down you want your house back
somebody steals your car suddenly your
car is on your mind you're like man I
really like that car I want to have it
back or even though was a piece of crap
car I still want it back as it was life
they want what they want yeah they're
missing camp and it's actually more for
just they're missing half it's a desire
for complete whole again being one thing
that's what we did all these beings at
the start what happens is they they seek
each other out you know the gods
separate in my house one of the
different places
yeah and they seek each other out when
they find each other they just kind of
hang out they grab on to each other cuz
I mean how else would you come back
together and then they start or they die
and so the guys are not getting any
sacrifices because these these human
beings are now dying on there kind of
useless that way so they put the the
genitals around in the front so they can
compelete and have some fun and then
after they do that first off if you know
a male and a female come together you
get some more new beings right more
sacrifices but even if it's just you
know other pairings at least they'll
have some fun get their they were
feeling you know satisfied to some
extent then they can get back on with
the business of making more sacrifices
or whatever else they're gonna do so
according to this idea this is sort of a
symbolic explanation of the way we are
each one of us is looking for our
missing half now we could be satisfied
with somebody else who does at least
meet the criteria of some of our desires
and one of those what are those desires
well this has to do with this notion
that he's got originally three sixes
these are the three possible
combinations at the start the ones who
are originally male male we need to
separate them out they want to be with a
male they specifically they want to be
with that male that was there they're
missing him but if they can't have them
or like they're missing half dies they
can at least find another male to be
with that's where their attraction lies
those who are female female same sort of
situation right split them down the
middle they want to find that missing
half who is a female and if she dies
well they can find somebody else at
least who's like her who fits the bill
and those of us who you know were in the
middle with the weird mixed kind of
thing now notice is really interesting
because we often think about in our
society this is the norm right and these
are that extremes you know we're not
like everything's out of what level
playing field but culturally no that's
not actually the case
everybody was one of these was
originally half and half these were all
male these are all female these are the
half and hence they're looking for their
missing Hammond and so if a man you know
his missing half dies well you can find
another woman if a woman
her missing half dies she can find
another man because that's where their
attraction will be that's where their
desire will be so this is really a story
about sexual desire sexual desire is not
what it appears to be it's not just
about getting on it's not just about
having fun it's not just about you know
all all the different things that we
experience when it comes to sex or
imagine or write about or talk about
it's about something deeper a need that
we can barely articulate for what's
missing what we've left what's what's
been taken away from us the only thing
that will make us truly happy according
to this is to be reunited with our
missing pair and even that is not going
to fully cut it right why not
so you find you're missing half
you know you sparks fly between you you
have what's called chemistry you autos
with dates you start sleeping together
that's a lot of fun and now you're very
close and intimate turns out you get the
same taste of music like saying movies
you go hiking together now you'd start
you know move in together or at least
you know put some third stuff at your
place or vice-versa
why isn't that enough what about to get
married when that like seal the deal tie
the knot
that's often how we think of that right
marriages are like it's all gonna be
easy street from down a lot yeah
exactly what we really want is to not
just spend time with the other person or
have things in common or have sex with
them or be romantic with that or pick
whatever you want or even do nice things
to them we want to be the same game we
want to be fused together
he says if have faced us never got you
know what like did all this kind of
stuff but God Smith so I suppose we'd
say the god of Technology we're to show
up and say do you think you'd like for
me to take you to and like weld you into
one being they'd be like that was it
that's what we wanted that's what we've
been seeking out so all of our other
desires all of our other ways of loving
are just sort of shadows of something
that's for us unattainable something
very interesting to think about in a way
it's not really a comic story in the end
this it's almost a tragic story you can
never truly have what we want
so that's here of stopping these [ __ ]
let's talk about this guy Agathon now
Agathon this is Johnny's murder
I guess that rising star it's his party
he just won the competition and it's
interesting because Socrates starts out
you know talking with them and he's like
yeah you're gonna do just fine
I'm worried about my school the Agathon
you're gonna be fine didn't you just
like blow them away yesterday
and a half times like you know it's a
whole different thing delivering tragedy
to a whole crowd of people it's a very
you know it's much more difficult much
more anxiety provoking to talk to people
actually know what they're talking about
isn't that the case if you ask
performers they will tell you that is
the case they can get up on a stage and
do it whatever they're gonna do but you
put it in the interview room one-on-one
with a tough interviewer they don't like
that because you know they they
minecraft and actors need lines
Agathon says you know that's that's my
real worry and that's actually going to
turn out to be the case so this is great
speech that he gets is gonna turn out to
be ultimately wrong well let's look at
the speech anyway so he says I'm gonna
write to some sport he says all of the
rest of you have been claiming to you
know do what we set out to do which is
what to praise lot but really you
haven't been doing that you've been
praising the gods gifts to human beings
you haven't been telling us what love
really is and why love is so good now is
that a fair charge
you think it is they haven't said
anything about the nature of love house
audience that didn't he phaedra stand it
seems like Eric stomach instead they may
have had different conceptions of it but
but they had some conceptions of was
didn't so he's starting off a kind of a
bad foot but but it seems plausible
that's that's really the key to his
speech it seems plausible until you
start poking it the way it's
constructive is actually very good he
says love is great for two reasons love
is beautiful or these will work fine in
the translation they can have the Greeks
have this term column that covers the
beautiful the honorable of fine you know
the aesthetically pleasing love is good
Agatha now notice his very name means
good in green love is good and he's
going to say love is beautiful in love
is good because point 1.2.3.4
love is good because of these things and
what is he actually going to provide us
with love his young love is tender love
his supple and love is you know has a
nice complexion afterthought
I met this person yesterday boy was was
she beautiful she was young she was you
know very soft soft skin
she was so graceful plushy a nice
complexion that's somehow it seems to be
you know not quickly up to the standards
but the way he talks about in terms of
flowers is nice
over here love is good he talks in terms
of the virtues virtues are ways of being
good for the Greeks and he talks about
justice temperance courage and wisdom so
Ghana has all these things God is really
the best now let's look at the actual
arguments does love actually he have
these characteristics so he says love is
the youngest of the gods and flees from
here so you know how do you know they
logged is young because we don't like
old people the old people don't make us
feel attractive younger people do this
is particularly interesting in our
culture which is obsessed with youth
isn't it it's funny to see all the baby
boomers right now people who are
retiring your grandparents generation
striving so so so hard to try to appear
youthful to try to stay in shape you
know to keep themselves regular with
Activia and yet you know somehow not
appear unsexy as a result so they're
really trying hard you got to give it to
him that's in they were the first youth
generation in America they're the first
ones to be really really centered on
that they were somehow all more in touch
with the essence of things so maybe
there is something to this you know the
notion of love being youthful the other
thing they says is love couldn't have
been around very long because if love
had met the gods wouldn't have done
these horrible things that we know they
do in Greek mythology to each other
because those are definitely necessity
what about tenderness he compares love
to another God and that God's name is
not a and not a means destruction and
destruction Homer tells us walks on the
heads of men now heads are kind of hurt
right cuz they have skulls in them what
is softer than ever gonna happen your
heart human hearts right hearts and
souls are the softest thing all together
and that's where love resides isn't it
in the human heart
so therefore love must be tender or soft
flexibility suppleness gracefulness this
is an interesting one this is not a bad
argument love can fold all things love
can make its way in secretly to the
human heart have you ever been surprised
by your attraction to somebody you
didn't know that you had to tell
suddenly it's there well that would be
loved sneaking into your heart and then
love abounds where there's flowers
flowers smell nice and look nice so love
is kind of like that not particularly
good you know but a nice image isn't it
sort of Valentine so what do you think
are these good arguments for love being
superlative ly beautiful plausible right
let's see where he's gonna go
so what about these virtues once a love
is actually good what does it mean for
the Greeks to be good to have these
characteristics justice means fairness
not making other people do things they
don't
being the you know being right in your
dealings with other people does lob do
this love doesn't make anybody do
anything they don't want to do bless you
everything they do is voluntary there's
no compulsion with love can you force
love can you make somebody above you
that I mean like you know weird
serial killer you know brainwashing in
the basement kind of stuff we just watch
the text or less that's okay can you
force alone no you can't right he came
to buy love with money you can buy sex
and you can't buy love love has to be
kind of earned or cajole or a response
to love so love can't do or Sakari
injustice so love must be totally just
love itself is justice temperance this
is a word that we're not used to using
we would say moderation instead
temperance we tend to think about
drinking alcohol right but your bodily
pleasures that you indulge it sleep
sacks food drink what else do we like
that could be tempered about speed you
know like people driving too fast on the
road because they like the feel of power
and that comes with that those could all
be manners of temperance is love
temperate well let's think about what
temperance does temperance controls our
desires and pleasures doesn't love
control our desires so long as
temperance love is temperance itself
courage
now here you relies on a what we call
turn the a fortiori type of party event
meaning well if you buy this than this
even more you know so he talks about the
God of War you guys are run you guys
know this story love conquers the god of
war
does anybody know this story up yeah let
me give it to you real quick because
we're almost out of time so love the
feeling of love conquers Ares the God of
War she gets in bed with the Aphrodite
the goddess of love no the problem is a
Aphrodite is married to infest us and
have Festus you know finding out that
he's being cuckold it means you're being
cheated on he doesn't like this so he
makes this net that leg comes down over
the lovers and this is like before
cameras right and then gotcha shows so
he strains them up in this net and then
he brings all the other guys who's like
look at this see what she's doing see
what he's doing I think there should be
some sort of penalty here so love was
able to conquer Ares the God of War and
the God of War is the most courageous
right so if you can conquer the God of
War you must be even more courageous
than the God of War you're totally
courageous love wisdom well love is a
poet and the source of poetry and others
he's created of the animals he inspired
all the arts so he must be supremely
wise now when you start looking at his
arguments I am want you to reconsider
them they're not actually very good
arguments there's holes play-doh wants
you to find those holes that's sort of
why he sent up the dialogue what he did
first they sound quite good and and
Agathon is going to bring this to a
close by going into this long speech
this paragraph right but all the things
that love does and it is like the finest
oratory that you can you can put on tap
it's sort of like listening to you know
somebody like Martin Luther King
great orator himself just get up and
everything follows from everything else
you know every single word is perfectly
chosen but you have to ask yourself is
this all the sort of glitz or does it
mean if that's where we're going to pick
up next
yeah like stay alive for so long oh
that's a good question
well he was he was what we would call
independently wealthy you know back then
it didn't take quite so much to be
independently wealthy because taxes were
not what they would they are for for us
and you didn't have quite so many
necessities and people lived quite a bit
closer to the land
Socrates want to give a couple of us so
Athens you guys know Athens as a slave
Society right most ancient societies
throughout the world as a matter of fact
every culture that that managed to get
to a certain level of development had
slavery servitude or some sort so there
was this underclass of people who are
doing work right that meant that you
could have a larger amount of the free
population sort of living off of their
Socrates you know he would have
inherited some wealth and then he could
have you know a lot of people they
inherit wealth and they do something
with it they add to it but socrates
chose to do instead is wander around the
city getting into conversations with
people and he saw this as a good thing
he saw this as taking care of his soul
and trying to urge his fellow citizens
to take care of their souls so he did
you know he wasn't just like doing
nothing at all sitting around playing
games all day but it was not renew
turrets of work from company as a matter
of fact he made an issue of the fact
that he didn't take money for teaching
and that's something you can do when you
when you're fairly wealthy you can
afford to do that that's a good question
so